parliament in sri lanka has begun the
process of choosing a successor to
deposed president gorabaya rajapaksa the
chamber will be selecting a new leader
to serve the rest of russia pax's term
after he fled the country on wednesday
following mass protests
the next president will urgently need to
tackle sri lanka's economic crisis
people are struggling with shortages of
many basic necessities like food fuel
medicine and fertilizer
well dw's my nero chowdhury is in
colombo forest hi mineral good to see
you so a new president should be
appointed next week how will they be
chosen
well pablo the process has begun the
parliament has convened today in fact it
is uh in progress right now as we speak
now the plan of action is that on july
20th a new president will be chosen
through a secret ballot both votes will
be cast by the parliamentarians through
a secret ballot at the moment what we
know are that there are three names in
the in the fray rana vikrama singha the
current prime minister and the acting
president has thrown his hat in the ring
and though he may have a little edge in
the secret ballot but uh it'll be
interesting to see what happens because
the public mood is still overwhelmingly
against him another name in the fray is
that that of dallas allah perumi who is
a member of the rajapaksa political
party and the third name is that of
sajid premadasa who is the leader of the
principal opposition party
maniro tell us what the new president
will have to do to restore confidence in
the political system in sri lanka
well yes the new president will have a
huge challenge in front of him because
people definitely uh have lost faith in
the current administration so he has he
will have a task cut out for himself
people will keenly look at what calls
will be taken in the first few days of
the person taking over the presidentship
one big demand since the beginning of
the protest has been the abolishment of
executive presidency which is a system
here in sri lanka which gives
overwhelming enormous powers to the head
of the state to the president so that
has been one demand and that has been
the demand of the protesters that
whoever takes over now
should be doing away with this system
minera it's been an intense week to say
the least in sri lanka
what if the past seven days meant for
the country's citizens
uh well july the ninth when people
stormed over and occupied the
presidential palace and presidential
secretariat that you see behind me was a
historic day for the people here and on
july the 13th they stormed and occupied
the prime minister's office as well
giving a clear message that they want
ranul vikrama singha also to step down
as the acting president and the current
prime minister so all these days clearly
were culmination of what people say was
their anger their frustration at the at
the administration at what they say the
fake the false promises that they have
been making they say that the occupation
of these buildings was in a way of show
of strength by these people by the
protesters who call this moment a publix
a people's movement a public uprising
and a symbol of what power the the
people hold in a working or should hold
in a working democracy so for them these
seven days have been reflecting that and
also they say that they they did get a
massive victory because after that day
got away pakistan had to flee and had to
ultimately resign which was their
biggest demand since the beginning
manira thanks for your reporting dw's
manira chowdhury in colombo
well for more on that we're joined by
ambika
sat kuna natan a human rights lawyer and
former commissioner of the human rights
commission of sri lanka welcome to dw so
for you as a human rights lawyer what
would be the most urgent challenges for
a new president to tackle
uh well i think before we get to the
challenges it is important that the
parliament elects the person who has
the public trust and also legitimacy
right now it appears that the person uh
who might be elected is the current
acting president ronald vikrama singh
who did not even win his seat to
parliament and against whose premiership
there has been a lot of opposition so i
think public trust and legitimacy is key
if the new president is to go ahead with
economic recovery because political
stability is important and we're not
going to get that if the new president
doesn't have public support that said
three things the new president would
have to do and to take forward is
abolition of the executive presidency
the law that allows them to call out the
armed forces to maintain law and order
that would have to be rescinded and not
reissued and finally elections a very
clear plan to hold elections as soon as
practically possible is the way out of
this impasse
so
how would people actually react if the
interim presidents or the former prime
minister actually um
goes into power
i think the public are already very
concerned about it you can see that in
the protest you can see that in social
media and if he is elected that would uh
lead to the protests continuing that
would lead to uh tensions it would lead
to more conflict and a lot of public
opposition which would create or
exacerbate the existing instability
which means we really can't focus on the
important issues like solving the
economic crisis and dealing with the
basic needs of the people who have been
subjected to immense suffering
let's talk about the former president
now
he and his family have been blamed for
mismanaging the country there there have
been allegations of war crimes and
corruption
would it not have been better if the
president didn't flee the country
well uh
if the president my personal opinion is
if the president had remained in the
country
that would have created more instability
as it is i think the presence of the
rajapaksa's continued presence means
continued instability because they are a
very effective opposition and their aim
is to get back into power plus the
history of the criminal justice system
in sri lanka does not inspire confidence
particularly in relation to holding
those responsible for human rights
violations accountable so perhaps since
universal jurisdiction is widely uh
widely used now increasingly used there
is perhaps a better chance of holding
him accountable outside the country than
inside
ambika sadkuna natan former commissioner
of the human rights commission of sri
lanka and a human rights lawyer thanks
for joining us on dw
thank you